surreal db an open source new sql
database that delivers every feature
you've ever dreamed of acid scalable
full text search real-time graph
relational multi-tenant temporal
schema-less schema full serverless
embedded are all words that can describe
surrealdb a multi-modal database that
combines elements of relational graph
and document paradigms into a simple
package that can be queried with an
sql-like language development was
started by jamie and toby morgan
hitchcock in 2015 and it was open
sourced in july 2022 the engine is
written in rust and can support multiple
persistence layers like tai kv to scale
horizontally in the cloud or as a single
node both in memory or on disk most
importantly though it can handle complex
relationships like traditional
relational databases but does so without
joins instead it uses techniques like
record links and graph connections that
not only handle complex data models but
also result in concise
developer-friendly code by default it's
schema-less which means you can
implicitly create unstructured data in
any table however you can opt into
schema full tables when the data model
becomes well-defined it's also asset
compliant allowing you to run
transactions across multiple tables
which also emit events when the data
changes so you can listen to real-time
updates from a front-end application
kind of like firebase and the feature
list goes on with things like geospatial
data and predefined analytics views all
of which can be locked down with
permissions out of the box to get
started install it on your machine then
run it locally with the cli then execute
code using its rest api or a client
library for your favorite language just
like sql we can use statements like
create to add a record to the database
every record has a unique id comprised
of two parts the left side is the table
the record belongs to and the right side
can be whatever you want or if left out
it will be automatically generated and
now you set to define the data for that
record or try content for a more
json-like syntax now that we have some
data populated we can query it with a
select statement it supports the where
clause to filter by a condition and has
a variety of built-in functions like
count to fetch aggregate data or is to
validate common data formats like an
email and if that's not enough you can
even embed your own javascript logic
directly into a query but remember there
are no joins in the surreal life instead
of foreign keys record ids can be stored
in any other record that makes it
possible to query that data using a
simple select statement that uses dot
notation to specify the fields that
should be joined in that takes care of
most relationships but you can even add
graph edges between records using the
relate statement you can now query this
data efficiently using arrows to
traverse between nodes and edges this
has been surrealdb in 100 seconds if you
want to go beyond 100 seconds check out
my new channel beyond fireship where
i'll be taking you on an extended
surreal journey thanks for watching and
i will see you in the next one